hello and welcome to this video playing
km no k BMC okay
it's tempting also you never know if
they actually know the Sicilian okay
maybe he's got some like a six is his
emergency line or something you never
know in case of yeah people going going
to e4 I'm kind of improvising yeah I
think I'm my default was a baton name
and this is compared to what I've looked
at when I prepared this but okay I mean
that cannot be a really bad position
you've got the pieces out
so I don't mind playing this all that
much it says some issue here it looks a
little bit always a little bit worried
about pieces being in some sort of like
being dependent from one another like
the knight never needed to be protected
by the Queen o is some tactic may be
possible yeah I was thinking that this
queen is rather annoying so and he
basically agrees but if I go here isn't
that still quite annoying okay I could
Bishop g5 now for quick development has
to go to g6 then Andrew q1 I'm not quite
sure but it looks on the other hand it's
black going to do next by the way and I
could be six McCamish up c5 maybe is an
idea also
okay let's do that
it took me a really long time to
register that actually this is chick
made oh my god it took me a really long
time I was I was thinking about ways to
get rook the Aiden but there is also
Queen d8 made oh my god
it is early in the day but still I
should spot that okay some this is some
I think anybody windy for this is a
decent line I mean black has a 6n which
is not super useful but of course you
can sorry
or to just take with the pawn yeah I
felt like just developing it's okay my
engine wants to go d6 immediately yeah
we my Norton Bishop takes d5 it's not
exactly a threat like if you go d6 I
mean this is not maybe you can even play
but should be six first but this is
simple and good and White has given up
the bishop their pair for nothing so you
don't need to necessarily reach reach
okay Bishop back d6 and yeah I can take
on the six but castling is fine and now
it took twice only five I mean we have
to see that it's difficult to develop
yeah it is really difficult to develop I
was expecting Queen to d6 and more than
Queen f6 and then I would have been I
would have played this Queen Queen g5
was my idea and Jen likes Queenie for me
I was thinking here because again there
should be seven is prevented and if
black I was age six which is suggested
by the computer Queen to h5 for h4 is
still annoying you cannot easily castle
sure due to the sacrifices and the twin
here's also preparing look do you want
some I'm very much head and development
and the position is open okay green you
have six think we need five looks fine
it is not it's not the top choice Queen
g3 or c7 Queen c7 Mason makes an awful
lot of sense as well okay but I mean
that it's probably not terrible 97 yeah
and I mean I had a complete I did not at
all see that it has Queen D ain't made
as my opponent also didn't see it but
that is really sick I was thinking I can
I somehow get yeah look here bishop here
and then yeah I really complicated ideas
like for example for example I know it
that doesn't work due to Queen f2 but I
saw a line like that yeah I'd just like
to see what was on my mind I saw this
idea but I did not really register that
it is Queen d8 made which makes Bishop
g5 basically um yeah a complete
transformation as he has to play b6 and
now what I've mentioned by
transformation and we have got a
completely different position now I take
the Queen takes my queen and I have to
go back I don't know D for loops no is
also the engine move and here of course
what must be better we have a White has
the better development and the doubled a
pawns are not really beautiful I mean
they're not going to fall that quickly
even though yeah but it's quit you know
it's not it's not very nice for for
black but still yeah this is what um
what would have happened if he and
overlook the main that's really funny I
didn't say it's either as you as you as
you saw a play we should be five and
only then I got its made okay anyway
thanks for watching